Speaker 1: So yesterday, I told you we would
talk about this today, and now I want to there
are starting to be numerous reports where the
headline is the Russia Ukraine war. The invasion
of Ukraine by Russia could last 10 to 20 years.
And I think it's important to understand that it
wouldn't be 10 to 20 years like the last six
days, but it's still important to understand
sort of what's at stake here. There's an
interesting article in the week called the
U.S. and Britain reportedly believe Ukraine war
could last 10 to 20 years and become a Russian
quagmire. And if you look at the details, it says
despite Moscow's shambolic start to its campaign,
most Western officials and analysts believe
Russia will turn to criminal siege tactics
and eventually find a way to break through
Ukraine's fierce and valiant resistance.
A U.S. official tells CBC News Russia could
tactically seize Kiev and Ukraine in four to
six weeks, so in terms of like now, four to six
weeks is being mentioned. But as this goes on,
the U.K. foreign secretary estimated it would be
a 10 year war. Lawmakers at the Capitol were told
Monday it is likely to last 10, 15 or 20 years and
that ultimately Russia will lose. Now, of course,
when you're thinking about those timeframes
we are talking about protracted sort of is
separatist type conflicts in border areas, not
10 to 20 years of nightly bombing of Kiev. But
that doesn't mean that it's not going to be
absolutely horrifying. Here's a little bit of a
discussion about this from earlier this week,
Speaker 2: but this is only going to get
uglier for the president of the United
States and for the people of Ukraine.
Members of Congress briefed that this this war
could go on 10 20 years. This could end up being
an albatross for the President Biden and his
presidency dealing with this. It absolutely could
be. And this we are watching live broadcast on
television, a human rights catastrophe. So for the
president who has said he's putting human rights
back at the center of the agenda, he's also drawn
a very bright line to say we won't use military
force to defend it. We will if you go a little bit
farther west and touch our NATO allies. But the
criticism has been such a bright line can actually
encourage Vladimir Putin to know the limits.
Speaker 1: So that is a question that is
increasingly coming up, which as well is Joe
Biden potentially going to have to go back on
that. But the main thing I want to focus on,
and I don't I don't believe that he will on
troops on the ground. I think he's not going to
do it. There's a separate economic question here,
which is can the Russian economy support a
conflict for 10 or 20 years? And the answer is
what many economic analysts are saying. And of
course, economic economic analyst predictions
are worth what most of us pay for them, which is
nothing but the idea that the damage economically
that Russia will take if there are four to six
more weeks of this itself may take 10 to 20 years
to recover from. And when you think about, well,
if that's the case, and where will Putin be in 10
or 20 years time, we don't even know if he's
sick now as increasingly as being discussed,
if it's going to be bad regardless. It's not a
disincentive to just continue fighting for Russia
now. I think the more likely scenario
Speaker 2: is
Speaker 1: this does not last as a war for 10
years. But it's the four to six weeks that's
being discussed. But the economic repercussions
do extend to a decade and beyond a decade, who
can predict, but certainly you know that that is
plausible. Look at Venezuela, right? I mean, you
know, they're not fighting a war, but they've had
a disastrous economic collapse and they survive.
But there's a question as to what what can society
sustain for these periods of time and isolated
countries survive? It's a matter of how much do
the people suffer? How much are the Russian people
willing or able to put up with? And if you go
back to the collapse of the Soviet Union, that
was one of the most rapid declines in standard
of living and quality of life that countries
have faced. And what's happening in Russia?
I don't want to say it would be equivalent,
but it would be probably the the biggest similar
decline or even close to in scope and size.
And you know, you look at the collapse of the
USSR and you talk about decreased life expectancy
and all of these other things. So when
we say 10 to 20 years, I mean, listen,
like every other prediction. Take it with a grain
of salt, but understand it could be bad for 10 to
20 years in Russia economically. It's not going to
be 10 to 20 years of what we've all been watching
on TV for six days. That is not possible,
but many other things could last that long